find a bigger stage a challenge for a
lot of entrepreneurs is the product or
service that you're selling isn't really
all that great or different it's just
average it's boring and it's one of the
main reasons why 80% of companies will
fail 80% of new businesses will fail in
the first five years because your stuff
is boring it's just ok its average what
you need to do first is find something
that's great
something that you can excel at and be
one of the best in the world that and
when you find that and for those of you
entrepreneurs who are on that path who
are doing something important who poured
your passion into this business that
you're creating and you're not just
creating average ok get by products and
services what you're doing is gonna
change the world when you get to that
point then you need to find a bigger
stage you need to let the world know
about what you're doing and how good you
are one of my favorite stories of Eminem
and when he was first getting started he
had a tough upbringing he came from a
broken home his parents weren't together
he lived with various members of his
family bounced around from state to
state he pursued rap because he loved
doing it but he couldn't make any money
off of it
he took jobs at restaurants too to just
make ends meet but he fought himself you
know what I'm really good I want to make
a business out of this I want to become
a professional rapper even though at the
time there were no white rappers right
people looked at him and laughed a year
you're white you're rapping what are you
crazy and he felt he was good enough
that he needed to find a bigger stage
and his bigger stage moment came in 1997
at the rap Olympics in Los Angeles when
he went there he was dead broke he had
nothing he had no money he was evicted
from his house then day before and that
night he had to break into his house
sleep on the floor just so he had a
place to sleep before going to LA for
the rap Olympics everything was on the
line for him and he went to the rap
Olympics in LA anyone 2nd place and that
was all he needed that was a turning
point
he went from totally bankrupt broke
everybody laughed at him - now bean
noticed and dr. Dre who was a producer
looked at him listen to his tapes and
said I want to sign this guy people said
Dre you're crazy dudes white said I
don't care he's purple if he can rap I
want to be working with him and that was
a start of Eminem's career he put all
this work effort passion love into
making his rap something meaningful but
it only really took off when he found
his bigger stage at the rap Olympics so
if you're really good at what you do if
you'd love doing if you're if you're
creating something special you're not
just selling an average product or
service there's something unique about
what you're doing and it's really making
an impact on people's lives then you
need to find your bigger stage moment
and it may be scary
it may mean jumping out of your comfort
zone and may mean doing things that you
haven't done before but if you want to
have a real impact if you want to really
build a significant business if you want
to look back on your luck and say yeah I
did that I'm proud of the the mark that
I left on this world then you need to
embrace the fear go with it anyway and
find your bigger stage opportunity
believe those are watching like the
video you can support me by clicking on
the link below in the description leave
a comment let me know what you think and
click on my face to subscribe to the
channel thank you so much I'll see you
soon